Marvel recently dropped a bombshell when
it announced that the blade franchise is
getting a reboot and that oscar-winning
actor Maher Sheila Ali is taking the
reigns as the new Eric Brooks in the few
days following that news it seemed
everyone at something to say about the
reboots there were plenty of tweets
expressing excitement over Ali's casting
and then there were those that weren't
so thrilled including one promise to
riot if original blade actor Wesley
Snipes wasn't involved with the new
movie and now Snipes is finally broken
his silence on the blade reboots and
I'll lease stepping into his shoes it
turns out Snipes is totally cool with
the whole thing and thinks you should be
too no no I'm crystal comicbook.com
obtained a statement from Snipes in
which he affirms that there are no hard
feelings toward Ally and he's not
disappointed over Marvel choosing to
reboot blade without him just complete
understanding eNOS statement Snipes even
used to Arabic phrases Salaam meaning
peace and inshallah meaning if God wills
this is extra special since Holly is
Muslim and Snipes practiced Islam from
1978 to 1988 according to the holo
bursts Snipes said in part to all the
daywalkers losing their minds right now
chillax
although the news comes as a surprise
it's all good
such is the business of entertainment
much peace to the MCU crew always a fan
honor and respect to the Grand Master
Stan Lee congratulations and Salaam -
Mahalo Ali a beautiful and talented
artist whose expressions I look forward
to experiencing for many years to come
inshallah we will someday work together
most importantly to my loyal fans the
incredible outpouring of love is
overwhelming I am grateful for the
neverending support it's always tricky
business when a studio decides to
reimagine a property with a brand new
face at the forefront and when it comes
to blade a movie that changed a
superhero genre forever and has
continued to influence comic-book
adaptations to this day there was an
even bigger risk for vicious attacks
from those opposed to the entire idea
why can't you just be nice
because the world is nice while the
blade reboot has already garnered some
backlash it hasn't been as bad as it
could have been considering the
circumstances according to vice Snipes
has long wanted to play the vampire
hunting daywalker again this is a classy
response from Snipes there's certainly a
chance that he feels a bit upset about
Ali taking over the franchise and
marveled not yet extending an offer to
appear in the reboot in some capacity
but Snipes seems genuine in his response
he's right in saying that reboots are
just part of the entertainment business
especially these days when Studios are
constantly looking to refresh properties
for new generations and draw in old fans
with the irresistible pull of nostalgia
it was really only a matter of time
before Marvel looked to what's largely
considered the grandfather of superhero
movies for a refresh as the studio maps
out its post infinity saga plans the
blade franchise rests in capable hands
without Lee and Snipes can understand
that his mentioned that he hopes to one
day work with a league could spark talk
of a potential blade reboot sequel in
which Snipes does actually have a role
but considering the first flick is
currently without a release date writer
or director those conversations probably
wouldn't amount to anything substantial
for quite some time with Snipes having
now broken his silence about the blade
reboots fans can now rest easy knowing
the only blood that will be spilt is the
blood that will go flying in the film
itself check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]